[Music]
this spring has seen the first statewide
teacher strikes in recent memory
teachers have a legitimate complaint for
college educated professionals their pay
in many states as mediocre and has
declined nationally by two percent in
real terms between 1992 and 2014 but the
notion that taxpayers are defunding
schools is just wrong
even as teacher salaries fell across the
land during that period inflation
adjusted per pupil spending grew by 27
percent but much of this funding has
gone to non instructional cost while
student enrollment was up 20 percent
over that 22 year period non teaching
staff was up by more than twice that 47%
teacher benefits are also more generous
than those are the taxpayers who pay for
them school teachers receive more than
three times the retirement benefits per
hour of work than the average civilian
employee look there's a deal to be
struck here but if teachers want
sustainable pay increases school
spending needs to be tackled in a way
that addresses the concerns of teachers
students and taxpayers what do you think
about the teacher strikes let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI